all right Mike we just got back from the
Gears of War Ultimate Edition for Xbox
one preview event saw multiplayer and
singleplayer I think you were most
excited about multiplayer yeah so back
in the day when Gears War first came out
I played a lot of the multiplayer I
thought it was you know they really
perfected that third-person shooting the
cover based shooting and it felt really
great as soon as I got back into it all
the muscle memory came back it was kind
of weird to see Gears of War with
without you know rose-colored glasses as
they say yeah for the event they had us
play the Xbox 360 version the original
one and then immediately go to the Xbox
one version so we can see that certainly
the graphical differences how did the
shooting feel - between versions Gears
of War has always been a game you know
it's had a lot of weight behind it is
there anything that they've done in this
Ultimate Edition that's different as far
as returning to the original game they
still have the bullets coming out of the
center of the screen so that does feel a
little different that was something I
never noticed until I went to the
sequels back in the day but now that
they brought it back you kind of noticed
that as opposed to coming out of the
rifle barrel right in two and three it
came out of the end of the gun as it
should but it was just a design tenet of
the first game that they wanted to come
out of the center of the screen because
I think looking back I think they were
still trying to figure out the
third-person shooting and cover
mechanics so once you've noticed that
it's kind of jarring until you get back
into the groove but there's still that
wait it feels much smoother now with 60
frames per second especially in
multiplayer when you're playing against
people who are you know generally better
than the AI it actually kind of aligned
with my memory more than the actual
first game did which was odd but being a
remaster I think that's what it's
supposed to do it's also kind of
interesting because there's some things
that they consciously decided not to
bring back into the first game for
example the downstate crawl was absent
yeah that's odd because I actually liked
it in the later games I felt like it
gave you a lot of strategy even when you
were down you could crawl behind cover
if someone's shooting at you from a
distance you could go towards your
teammates and sort of help them out when
they're trying to pick you back up and
it felt very jarring not to have that
because I felt really helpless and I
think I still instinctively was just
a when I went down and as far as things
they did bring back you can also mark
enemies to show your teammates where
they are if they're not sure that's
another thing that came along in the
later sequels after the original 360
game and I think that's a good thing to
bring back I think it kind of helps your
team coordinator where the enemies are
it kind of improve your communication if
you're not necessarily just relying on
the microphones which of course is
always great anyway but it just gives
you another layer to how you communicate
with your team and I think it was a good
call to bring it back it felt great it
helped me out I think it helped my
teammates out in the long run we also
got a chance to check out single player
we played co-op so I love the my old
favorite weapons such as the hammer of
dawn it felt very similar to me as the
old I mean it was graphically upgraded
but again it felt very classic they did
say that they added what an extra two
hours of content that was only on PC for
the Ultimate Edition yeah there was
these two hours late in the game that
was only ever only ever came out on the
PC version that never made it to console
so this is technically the first time
it's ever on consoles with the Xbox one
version and we played a little bit of
that they kind of ended us right at up
this boss fight with a brew Mac that
people have played on PC will remember
but yeah other than that it doesn't feel
too much different I mean the first
Gears of War people always said that the
campaign was much more horror inspired
than the following two even though two
and three we're both very dark as well
but it definitely feels like they're
going back to that more confined setting
for the most part and you know there's
like the hammer of dawn sequences I
didn't really notice too much stutter
there are a few points I think when we
were fighting larger enemies when we
first saw the brew Mac on screen and the
Reavers in the air and using the hammer
of dawn like you mentioned it kind of
showed a little bit of stutter but
nothing that was too invasive and it
yeah I just felt like the original Gears
of War just obviously looks much better
and feels a little smoother which is
nice now that the Ultimate editions been
announced it's a little bit strange
timing because backwards compatibility
for Xbox one was also just announced how
do you feel about buying the Ultimate
Edition versus maybe just waiting for
the backwards compatibility for the
original gears two and three well I
think there are a few reasons it just
feels better especially in the
competitive multiplayer maps it's nice
to have 60 frames per second it's nice
to have these maps that look gorgeous
compared to what they used to they kind
of got rid of the
really dark gray muddy texture that kind
of pervaded the original game it's also
funny you mentioned backwards
compatibility because if you buy Gears
of War Ultimate Edition for $40 and play
it before New Year's Eve this year
you'll also get the Xbox 360 versions of
Gears of War 2 Gears of War 3 and Gears
of War judgment on Xbox one as part of
Microsoft's backwards compatibility plan
awesome thanks Mike
no problem